we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's an interesting voicemail about
the entire please define what a woman is
a thing including my recent appearance
on the michael knowles daily wire show
and this is another aspect to this which
is
why are these people
so obsessed with
genitalia maybe we should focus on that
take a listen
david i'm sorry i'm not done your
appearance on the michael knows show
like really triggered me
um
just this idea that he's saying that
women
you know the definition of women is the
most important thing in america you have
to push back on that make him feel like
a pervert because he's being a pervert
when he says that
you got to say
you really think whether or not a 13
year old has a penis you think what's
inside of the pants of
kids is more important than
potential nuclear war it's more
important than north korean tests how we
respond to that it's more important to
assessing our interventions overseas and
do we send troops to ukraine what what
do we do in ukraine discussion of
kids
genitals is more important to you and
more interesting to you than
foreign policy than
domestic tranquility than literally any
other issue yeah so it's an interesting
idea which is to push back when when
they do this stuff and say
it's more applicable to the bathroom
stuff i would say than to like you know
the katanji brown jackson hearing maybe
and just the general definition of women
but i think it's a fair thing to say
why are you so obsessed with the
genitals of kids
nobody's paying attention to that are
you saying you would if you were in a
bathroom with children it's a it's a
rhetorical approach i don't think it's
super substantive but sometimes you've
got to win the rhetorical battle so i
understand thinking about it very
interesting let me know what you think
but i i have
it could backfire if not done correctly
that would be the concern we have a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about the new billionaire tax not
millionaire billionaire tax proposed by
joe biden
we will talk about
a new um uh
i don't know what to call it a new
initiative from uber where in new york
city
all new york taxis will be listed in the
uber app it's very interesting why this
is happening and when pat joins me we're
going to try to figure out what happened
yesterday at the oscars where will smith
slapped chris rock and um we have some
more information about it than we did
now at the start of the show so we will
talk about that on today's bonus show
all of that and more and you can access
it instantly by signing up at
joinpackman.com
you can use the coupon code wow 22 to
get a discount we do depend on the
support of our viewers and listeners so
i would love it if you signed up at
joinedpakman.com and it comes with great
perks like being able to access the
bonus show you also get a commercial
free audio and video stream of the show
every day
six hours before it is published and so
many other great perks including a
forthcoming
town hall which i will tell you more
about next week see you on the bonus
show or otherwise sadly if you're not a
member we'll have to wait until tomorrow
to be together again